criticism makes our best work absolutely
listen I I believe in kind criticism so
I don't believe in cruelty for the sake
of cruelty but I don't believe that we
learn much from compliments I think they
can certainly boost our ego and make us
feel good but the learning happens from
criticism or the learning happens from
where we can improve what we can do
better that's how we grow well you know
flattery and compliments feel great
we're not going to walk out a better
writer tomorrow because of what we
learned from the compliment we're going
to put perhaps be more self-assured in
what we did originally well which is
great and I'm not discounting that but
criticism is what teaches us and
challenges us to become our best well
that's the internal dialogue that you
had when you decided that screenwriting
for you sitting down writing a script
maybe wasn't what you wanted to do what
you wanted to coach people you want to
bring out their best for me it was
really in the development process when I
realized what a foolish child I was
thinking that you can write a script and
then fast forward six or nine or twelve
months and see it brought to the screen
and being on set what when watching your
vision come to life I understood that I
came to it from a very naive point of
view from a fantasy based point of view
that wasn't the reality of what of how
movies get made and what the writers
experiences and I ultimately realized
that that wasn't the experience that I
wasn't I wanted to have or the
experience that would make me happy or
fulfilled in my day-to-day life and I
was lucky enough to have discovered that
at a fairly young age at the age of 23
to say well that no not for me I'm not
enjoying this this is nothing about this
is exciting or motivating for me that
said I always loved the story and I
always loved writers so from there and
went to development and really realized
my heart was with the writer the writers
were my people more so than the
directors that I never really got or the
actors that I dated but never
really got so my heart was with the
writers and so I wanted to foster talent
I wanted to support writers and it's
funny because today if I watch a tennis
game and somebody wins the person wins
and goes out and you know jumps up and
down they're so excited the person
identify with us not the tennis player
the person I identify with is the coach
that you get like one second of who's
just so proud and so and feel so
rewarded for what their player had done
and that's for me that's the most
fulfilling experience being able to help
others and being in a position where
somebody comes to me and says I need
help I think that's a highly privileged
position to be asked to provide help in
an area in which I can help have you
seen people that have the notion whether
it's to be a great pianist or to be a
great writer but in terms of the day to
day actions that they're going to
undergo it's actually not what they're
suited for oh absolutely and and what
what are those what is that temperament
and what is it just it's being alone as
being self driven task orient its not
just that I know a lot of writers and
these I'll put in quotation marks who
talked about writing all the time who
talk about what they want to write and
how much they want to be a writer and
how much they want to be in a room and
how much but never make time for the
writing itself so to me those those are
the writers that will usually bring me a
comment to the conversation of do you
really want to write because you're
talking about it all the time when
you're not actually doing it and if you
are a writer who is not writing then
what are you in terms of this career you
have to have the discipline you have to
have the desire you have to have the
drives and you have to be willing to
make the sacrifices that most writers do
that it takes in order to become a
writer and that means waking up in the
morning early if you have a day job
sorry or writing on the weekends or
writing after hours rather than running
around partying with your friends
there's a lot of for most writers most
writers are not independently wealthy
right they're not going to be able to
sit around all day and take four hours a
day to write and then go
party and then go run around and then go
travel the world so most writers are
going to find themselves in a situation
where they have to have a day job
potentially they have a family they have
a partner they have friends they have
relationships they want to maintain and
so writing is going to demand some level
of sacrifice
I had a writer that I had worked with
for a number of years who we would meet
every three or four months and every
three or four months she would sit down
and tell me the list of excuses for why
she didn't write the previous three or
four months so the job was too hard and
she had to work out because she wasn't
healthy and she wasn't sleeping well and
she had to move apartments and she was
fostering dogs there was always
something and I truly believe that she
wanted she believed she wanted to be a
writer but at the end of the day if
you're not engaging in the thing right
whether it's writing or playing piano or
any one of the things you cannot claim
this thing as your own you have to
engage in it in some consistency and you
know similarly I meet writers who wrote
a screenplay ten years ago and haven't
touched it since but they're a writer
but you have to actively engage in this
thing if you want to be taken seriously
as an owner of the thing